We're at Michael's, in Phoenix
Arizona
with talented comedian Bryan
Ricci, Terrence DeLane,
Jill Kimmel, James McCowen.
JayMac is what they call you.
Yes, sir.
In Phoenix, is
there a comedy scene?
Do you guys think there's a--
- Big scene.
Yeah.
- --a big comedy scene here?
- Underrated for sure.
- Really?
Yes.
Got a lot of
great clubs in town.
What about rooms as well?
Are people doing the
whole room thing?
Yeah, I have an open mic
I've been running for--
Ever.
--six and a half years,
every Tuesday night.
Like, at a restaurant,
a Mexican restaurant.
It's a crummy
joint, nobody comes.
But the comics come, and
they run their material,
and you do what you got to do.
That's good.
One thing I will say
about Phoenix is it makes
you well-rounded as a comedian,
because there's not urban
rooms.
There's no room that you can go
to to just work an urban set.
So you have to kind of,
you know, stick and move--
KEVIN: Some of everybody here.
--and be diverse.
Absolutely.
- That's a good thing.
- Yeah, for sure, for sure.
So how many years you got in?
I've been doing it 16 years.
16.
And when you're doing it long
like that, you get people--
I get people asking
me, they haven't
seen me in a little bit.
OK.
Be like, hey, Bryan, you
still doing that comedy thing?
- Right.
- You mean my life?
Like, you don't--
You still following
that dream, Bryan?
- Yeah!
- What about you?
I've been doing it
little bit over four years.
OK.
I wanted to be a
gangsta rapper first.
I wanted to be a rapper first.
My boy just signed me up
for an open mic one night.
I thought I was
going to do a song.
He was like--
That's an amazing segue.
I was gonna be a gangsta
rapper, that's what it was.
And I got on stage and I
was like, I'm funny as shit.
[all laughing]
Jimmy Kimmel is your brother.
And how is that for you
doing stand-up comedy?
Is that a clutch?
You know, I started doing
comedy, I was married,
so I had a different last name.
No one except comics knew
that I was related to him.
I get on stage, none of
my material is about him.
It's great to look at him and
see what he's accomplished.
I'm very proud of him.
But as far stand-up
goes, that's all me.
You got to do it yourself.
"Hart of the City."
Big moment for you guys.
What do you want
from this moment?
I want to get bookings.
I want to possibly become
your stunt double in movies.
[all laughing]
You got a bunch of movies
every month, you know?
I've been working out lately,
you know what I'm saying?
Stunt double, you
don't want that process.
I done seen that move before.
These guys get fucked up.
The shit they do to
me in these movies.
All right, this is where Kev
gets thrown through the glass.
You ready, Jay?
[heavy sigh]
[laughing]